triangle Sam s a.m. and this is this one
Revere s a.m. is rotated 270 degrees
about the point 4 comma negative 2 so
this is 4 comma negative 2 right over
here draw the image of this rotation
using the interactive graph and we have
this little interactive graph tool where
we can draw points so if we want to put
them in the in the trash we can put them
there the direction of rotation by a
positive angle is counter clockwise so
this would be 270 degrees in the
counterclockwise direction
so to help us think about that I've copy
and pasted this on my scratch pad and we
can we can draw through it and the first
thing that we might want to think about
is if you rotate and I've talked about
this in the previous video when we were
rotating around the origin
if you rotate something by last time we
talked about a negative 270 degree
rotation but if we're talking about a
270 degree rotation if you imagine a
point right over here this would be 90
degrees 180 and then that is 270 degrees
that is a 270 degree rotation we're
going in a counterclockwise direction
you see that that is equivalent that is
equivalent to a 90 degrees to a 90
degrees clockwise rotation or a negative
90 degree rotation and 90 degree
rotations are a little bit easier to
think about
so let's instead of thinking of this in
terms of rotating 270 degrees in the
positive direction in the
counterclockwise direction let's think
about let's think about this rotating
this is 90 degrees in the clockwise
direction they are going to be
equivalent but how do we do that well
like we've done in previous videos what
I'm going to do is I'm going to take
each point let's say point is in a color
you can see Point M I'm having trouble
switching go point M right over here
and I'm going to construct a right
triangle between point M and our center
of rotation where the hypotenuse of the
right triangle is going to be the line
that connects these two so let me draw
that so that's the hypotenuse and let me
draw a right triangle like this so it's
going to go it's going to be like it's
going to look like that and then it's
going to look like whoops that wasn't to
press my command button before okay
there you go
right so I have this right triangle so
if you imagine imagine rotating this
right triangle this magenta one that I
just constructed by negative 90 degrees
by negative 90 degrees or 90 degrees in
the clockwise direction well what's
going to happen to each of these sides
well this side right over here if I
rotate it by negative 90 degrees it is
going to end up it is going to end up it
is going to end up pointing up and how
long is it going to be well see this one
is one two three four five six seven
units long so it's still going to be
seven years long one two three four five
six seven it's going to put us right
over here it is going to put us right
over there and then this side let me
make this clear this side that I'm
highlighting in green which we see is
four units long it forms a right angle
it forms a right angle so if you were to
rotate this entire triangle 90 degrees
in the clockwise direction whether this
is going to go for in this direction
just like that just like that and then
your new triangle the image of I guess
what we just this this right triangle
I've constructed if I rotate it by
negative 90 degrees 90 degrees in the
clockwise direction is going to look
like this so after rotation so what did
I just do I just took this I just took
this triangle that I constructed and I
rotated it negative 90 degrees to get to
this triangle right over here and so the
point M it's image after the 90 degree
rotation is would be right over here and
I could call that I'll call that M Prime
what I'm essentially going to do I'm
going to that for point M I'm going to
do that point for point a and I'm going
to do that for point s and I'm going to
connect the three the M Prime the a
prime of the s prime and then that will
give me the image that will give me the
vertices of my new triangle the image of
triangle Sam after rotation so let's
keep going let's do this let's do this
now with point a with 0.8 and I can
construct another right triangle
and I could do it I could do it several
I could do it several ways actually let
me just do it this way let me let me
draw it I could I could draw this the
hypotenuse we know is going to go from
here to from point A to our Center of
origin and I could draw a right triangle
that's up here like this or I could draw
a right triangle that is down here like
this
maybe I'll focus on this one let me draw
this right triangle so this right
triangle right like this so if I draw
this right triangle like this so this
side let me do this in a color but I can
see more clearly or that is let's see
this side no you won't be able to see
that all right I'm gonna stick with the
purple so this side right over here that
I am drawing in purple if you rotate it
clockwise in the 90-degree direction or
negative 90 degree rotation well it's
going to instead of being straight
horizontal is going to be straight
vertical so it's going to be it's going
to be it's going to overlap with what we
had already drawn and how long is it
well right now it goes from x equals
negative 5 to x equals 4 so it's 9 long
and you can count that 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
or you could say it's 2 longer than what
we had already drawn so let's see if you
if you start y equals negative 2 and you
add 9 you're going to get 2 y equals 7
so this is going to go all the way like
this and then and then let's see this
side this side forms a right angle with
it so if you so it's going to go like
this it's going to be a right angle and
how long is this it's 1 2 3 4 5 units
long so now we're going to go 1 2 3 4 5
units in that direction and just like
that we get to our a prime we get we get
2 we get to our a prime and we could
draw the hypotenuse of of this triangle
so let me see if I can draw it
so press you can draw the straight line
all right it's going to look like going
to look like that so we know where the
image of point M is after the rotation
we know where the image of point a is
after rotation and we see how these
triangles you constructed we've just
rotated them
we've just rotated them 90 degrees in
the clockwise direction now we just have
to do this for point s and then we have
the three points for our image so Point
s once again we can construct a right
triangle let's do that so hypotenuse
will connect point s to our center of
rotation and I could do this several
ways let me think about the best way to
do it well let me construct this right
triangle so it looks like this and then
it looks like this so this top side this
top side right over here if I were to
rotate it if I were to rotate it
negative 90 degrees or 90 degrees in the
clockwise direction where does that put
us well once again it's going to put us
straight up and down and this length is
it goes from x equals negative 3 to x
equals 4 it's so it's seven long so it
gets us to this point right over here
now this side let me be careful when I
just say this let me do it in a
different color this side right over
here forms a right angle and so it's and
if you see when you go from here you go
down so if you're going to go left and
you see this is three long so it's three
it's three long this is a right angle
right over here and then that gets us to
our s prime that gets us to our s prime
we can now draw the hypotenuse so notice
this whole like kind of crazy complex
that we have drawn of these different
triangles I've just rotated the whole
thing by negative 90 degrees that this
triangle that we have that we were we
had just made when you rotate it it maps
to that one right over there but now we
have in our image our s prime or a prime
on our M prime and we can connect them
so it will look like this so let's just
connect them
make the dots so that that and that
and so you see you might you might have
lost our original our original try our
original triangle I'm just going to
shade it in so you can see it clear
although what we really care about is
mapping the points mapping actually let
me I don't want you to think that we're
mapping that we're mapping everything
in-between
we're just mapping the points that
define the triangle so our original
triangle that we cared about was this
thing that I'm going to draw really bold
it was this thing and I'm gonna draw
really really really bold and you rotate
it by negative ninety degrees which is
equivalent to positive 270 you could
have rotated positive 270 you could have
rotated it positive 270 to get to this
other one right over here but it maps to
this this is its image now we just have
to go back on to the exercise now we
have to go back on to the exercise and
put it in so let's remember these points
we have the point 8 comma 5 so we have
the point 8 comma 5 in our image we have
the point 9 comma 7 9 comma 7 and we
have the point and we have the point 1
comma 5 so we have the point 1 comma 5
and now I just have to finish it by
going to this point again and we're all
done we've rotated it by 270 degrees
which is equivalent to a negative 90
degree rotation we can check that we
indeed got it right